meine damen und herren die aktuellen
täglichen zahlen des robert koch
instituts sind für uns alle anlass zur
hoffnung
sie machen uns auch mut denn langsam
geht zumindest im augenblick die zahl
der neuinfektionen zurück und man muss
sagen gott sei dank haben wir auch
weniger menschen auf den
intensivstationen zur behandlung und da
spricht alles dafür dass die harten
einschnitte die die menschen in
deutschland auf sich genommen haben sich
auszuzahlen beginnen und dafür möchte
ich von herzen danken
gleichwohl haben die ministerpräsidenten
und ich uns entschlossen uns nicht erst
am 25
januar wieder zu treffen und zu beraten
sondern bereits heute und dafür haben
wir einen wichtigen grund denn all
unsere bemühungen die ausbreitung des
virus einzelnen droht eine ernsthafte
gefahr die wir heute klarer sehen als
wir das am 15 januar konnten und das ist
die mutation des virus wie sie vor allem
aber nicht nur in großbritannien und in
irland aufgetaucht ist warum liegt darin
eine solche gefahr weil die bisherigen
epidemiologischen erkenntnisse daran
darauf hindeuten dass dieses mutierte
virus sehr viel ansteckender ist und das
ist eine hauptursache für den gewaltigen
anstieg der infektionen sowohl in
großbritannien als auch in irland ist
bei uns ist dieses mutierte virus
nachgewiesen worden allerdings wissen
wir nicht ganz genau in welcher menge
aber einzelne fälle sind bekannt die
wissenschaftler sagen uns dass es noch
nicht dominant ist
noch ist gewissermaßen zeit die ganze
gefährlichkeit auch einzudämmen
und es wäre natürlich vollkommen falsch
daraus jetzt zu schließen dass wir dann
auch noch wirklich alle zeit der welt
hätten um zu handeln
wir müssen jetzt handeln und das hat
mich jedenfalls aber auch uns alle
bei den beratungen heute bewegt jetzt
ist die zeit um der gefahr die in diesen
mutierten virus steckt vorzubeugen es
geht also um vorsorge und wenn sich die
mutation bei uns schon ausgebreitet
hätte dann könnten sich die
infektionszahlen dass es ist ja was wir
in anderen ländern gesehen haben
exklusiv erhöhen
mit der folge dass dann auch unsere
krankenhäuser in eine schwer zu
beherrschende lage geraten würden
deshalb haben wir heute noch einmal
beraten und auch zusätzliche maßnahmen
und einschränkungen beschlossen um den
rückgang der infektionszahlen in
deutschland noch einmal deutlich zu
beschleunigen
darin geht es wir wissen wenn die
infektionszahlen gering sind hat auch
das mutierte virus wenig chancen sich
weiter auszubreiten
und deshalb setzen wir auf dem weg den
wir gerade haben sinkende
infektionszahlen wollen diesen weg
beschleunigen durch zusätzliche
maßnahmen das heißt also wir tun das aus
vorsorge für unser land
aus vorsorge für die gesundheit der
bürgerinnen und bürger aber eben auch
aus vorsorge für die wirtschaft und die
arbeitswelt die unter einer
explosionsartigen anstieg dann doch sehr
stark bleiben würde
zu den beschlüssen im einzelnen der ich
hier hervorheben dass wir uns zuerst
einmal darauf geeinigt haben dass wir
alle maßnahmen die bis zum 31 januar
befristet waren bis zum 14 februar
verlängern müssen
das ist natürlich ein gewaltiger schritt
und wir wissen auch was das für die
bürgerinnen und bürger aber auch für
andere bedeutet zweiter bleibt es bei
der haupt der privaten zusammenkünfte
die erlaubt sind also ein haus stand mit
einer weiteren nicht zum hausstand
gehörenden personen
wir weisen aber daraus darauf hin dass
es in technologisch dann am besten ist
wenn die zahl der personen mit dem man
sich trifft eine kleine ist und
möglichst konstant ist damit sozusagen
nicht immer wieder kontakte und
infektionsketten entstehen können
wir erweitern die pflicht zum tragen
von medizinischen masken also op masken
oder auch masken von der qualität ffp 2
oder 1 95 m 95 um eine höhere
schutzwirkung zu haben das gilt für die
öffentlichen verkehrsmittel und für die
geschäfte verbindliche pflicht also das
zu tragen und generell wird auch in
situationen wo ein engerer oder längerer
kontakt ist zu anderen personen die
nutzung medizinischer masken angeraten
das ziel von uns ist dem die kontakte im
öffentlichen personennahverkehr so zu
reduzieren dass das theater ist
aufkommen deutlich zurückgeht dass in
der regel die abstände gewahrt werden
können und wie wollen wir dieses ziel
erreichen einmal durch weitgehende
nutzung von home office möglichkeiten
hier sind wir weit hinter den werten die
wir im märz hatten des vergangenen
jahres zurück indem wir das alles tun um
das fahrgastaufkommen zu entfernen den
stoßzeiten des berufs und schülerverkehr
und eben ergänzend die pflicht zum
tragen medizinischer masten
wir haben lange gerungen um das was im
bereich kinder und schule notwendig ist
wir alle wissen dass es unglaubliche
einschränkungen mit sich bringt für die
betroffenen kinder für die betroffenen
eltern aber es gibt ernstzunehmende
hinweise dass die mutation w 11 7 das
co2 virus sich auch stärker unter
kindern und jugendlichen verbreitet als
das bei den bisherigen virus der fall
ist und diese hinweise müssen wir ernst
nehmen und deshalb verweisen wir noch
einmal auf den beschluss vom 13
dezember 2020 wir müssen ihnen bis zum
14 februar 2020 verlängern
und wir müssen auf eine restriktive
umsetzung dieses beschlusses dringen
darauf haben wir uns auch gar nicht nach
langer diskussion
danach bleiben die schulen grundsätzlich
geschlossen beziehungsweise die
präsenzpflicht bleibt ausgesetzt und in
kindertagesstätten wird analog verfahren
wir wissen was die erzieherinnen und
lehrer leisten und sagen deshalb dreimal
deutlich dass wir ihnen danken für das
was sie in der bewältigung der pandemie
gerade bei den kindern und jugendlichen
leisten
wir kommen noch einmal zurück auf die
alten und pflegeheime wir haben hier in
den letzten tagen noch einmal durch die
bereitschaft von 10.000
bundeswehrsoldaten zu helfen um die
testung durchzuführen
auch noch mal einen praktischen schritt
getan und das war's für alten und
pflegeheime gilt gilt auch für die
einrichtungen von menschen mit
behinderungen das ist ganz wichtig weil
die rechtlich woanders verankert sind
und oft vergessen werden das wollen wir
ausdrücklich nicht wir sagen etwas zu
gottesdiensten in kirchen synagogen und
moscheen und die zusammenkünfte anderer
glaubensgemeinschaften sie sind nur
unter strikten voraussetzungen gestattet
abstand halten maske auch medizinische
maske tragen und untersagung des
gemeinde gesangs zusammenkünfte mit mehr
als zehn teilnehmern sind beim
zuständigen ordnungsamt spätestens zwei
werktage zuvor anzuzeigen
sofern es sich schon generelle
absprachen mit der religionsgemeinschaft
mit bestimmten behörden gibt
zentraler punkt heute in unseren
diskussionen war neben schule und kita
noch einmal das arbeiten im home office
hier gehen wir jetzt rechtlich vor die
frage hatten wir ja auch am fünften
januar schon diskutiert der minister für
arbeit und soziales wird eine verordnung
befristet bis zum 15 märz erlassen
wonach arbeitgeberinnen und arbeitgeber
überall dort wo es möglich ist den
beschäftigten das arbeiten im home
office ermöglichen müssen sofern die
tätigkeiten das zu lassen
und wir gehen davon aus dass dadurch
kontakte am arbeitsort aber auch auf dem
weg zur arbeit reduziert werden und wir
bitten die arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer diese angebote auch
wirklich zu nutzen da wo präsenz weiter
erforderlich wollen wir natürlich auch
einen möglichst guten schutz der
beschäftigten deshalb auch die belegung
von räumen reduzieren wo nicht
ausreichende abstände möglich sind
müssen medizinische masken getragen
werden und wir bitten die
arbeitgeberinnen und arbeitgeber darauf
hin
zu wirken das zur entzerrung des
fahrgastaufkommens im öffentlichen
personennahverkehr auch anfangs und
endzeiten der arbeit variiert werden
damit wir die digitalisierung die ja
sehr viel mit dem home office zu tun hat
voranbringen werden noch einmal
besondere abschreibe möglichkeiten
geschaffen
ich glaube das ist ein guter schritt
auch als anreiz und das lohnt sich ja
auch für die kommende zeit wir gehen auf
ein dass die instanz von 50 wie wir sie
uns ja vorgenommen haben in vielen
landkreisen nicht erreicht wird und dass
deshalb weiterhin über die allgemeinen
regeln hinaus gehende umfangreiche
lokale und regionale maßnahmen dort
getroffen werden können wo eben diese
instanz noch nicht erreicht wird
damit wir sozusagen langsam uns dann in
einem geleitzug auch in richtung der 50
pro 100000 einwohner in sieben tage als
incident bewegen können
wir haben dann noch mal lange über das
impfen gesprochen
hier sind wir natürlich von der
verlässlichkeit der produzenten abhängig
wir haben das jetzt alle erlebt dass
pfizer plötzlich diebisch die
lieferungen verändert hat das ist von
großen auswirkungen für die gesamte
logistik der länder und wir haben uns
miteinander verabredet dass wir von
unserer seite alles tun wollen um
erstmal bis zum ende des sommers jedem
bürger in impfangebot zu machen sind
dabei natürlich aber abhängig davon dass
die impfdosen an dann auch wirklich zur
verfügung gestellt werden wollen aber
von unserer seite aus werden wir alles
tun und wir haben uns mit der
sequenzierung beschäftigt denn wir
erwarten jetzt dass wir doch
mehr informationen bekommen über dieses
mutierte virus und der bund wird es
anfang februar hier eine erste
auswertung vorlegen die experten
insbesondere professor drosten haben uns
gestern gesagt dass in zwei bis drei
wochen eine gute chance besteht hier
eine bessere quantitative analyse zu
bekommen wir haben noch einmal darüber
gesprochen wenn wir eine eröffnungs
strategie miteinander vereinbar
dass es dann natürlich notwendig ist die
wiedererlangung und aufrechterhaltung
der kontrolle über das
infektionsgeschehen zu haben
und das heißt dass wir eine vollständige
kontakt nachverfolgung garantieren
können
und das bedeutet dass die
gesundheitsämter personell und
organisatorisch noch verstärkt werden
müssen und diese zeit die wir jetzt
haben bis zum 15 februar die müssen wir
nutzen um dafür die voraussetzungen zu
schaffen
dazu soll das system nord sommers
eingesetzt werden beziehungsweise
schnittstellen geschaffen werden damit
eine bundesweite kommunikation und eine
einfachere kontakt nach verfolgung
möglich ist ein letztes wort von meiner
seite zu dem thema europa wir werden am
donnerstag einen europäischen rat als
video konferenz haben wo wir uns neben
der impfung auch mit dem thema mutation
beschäftigen werden
und es ist vollkommen klar und von
vielen hier heute auch gesagt von dem
von den ministerpräsidenten deutschlands
ist umgeben von vielen ländern und wir
können hier tun und lassen was wir
wollen
wir werden keinen erfolg haben wenn ich
andere synchronen auch daran arbeiten
ich weiß dass nachbarländern wie
dänemark und niederlande sich heute auch
damit beschäftigt haben maßnahmen zu
verstärken
aber wir müssen sicherstellen dass hier
wirklich alle unsere nachbarländer in
die gleiche richtung arbeiten wenn das
nicht der fall ist müssen wir eben auch
vorkehrungen treffen bei einreise fragen
weil wir uns das was die bürgerinnen und
bürger hier leisten und was wir ihnen
auferlegen natürlich nicht sozusagen
wieder zunichte machen lassen dürfen in
denen wir das virus dann immer wieder
eintragen und das ist auch ein großes
thema und das ruft nach einheitlich
europäischen vorgehen das bezieht sich
nicht nur auf die eu sondern zb auch auf
nachbarländer wie die schweiz die ja
nicht zur europäischen in ihre mitte das
waren im wesentlichen unsere beschlüsse
ist lange gedauert ich glaube es hat
sich gelohnt
es ist hart was wir jetzt den menschen
noch einmal zumuten müssen aber das
vorsorgeprinzip hat für uns vorrang und
dem müssen wir jetzt auch rechnung
tragen und dem haben wir also auch
rechnung getragen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren